Hey, David, when it comes to Corona virus,
are we the only country smearing doctors who
are trying to save lives like.
Dr. Anthony Foushee, it's a good question.
Anthony Foushee has been smeared widely by
the Corona virus protesters who have been
saying for more than a month now we've got
to open it up.
We never should've closed it down.
We saw chance of fire foushee at a number
of different protests.
We more recently I covered this earlier in
the week, we saw signs that say Hang Foushee
and hang Belak, Bill Gates as well.
But the truth is that we are not the only
country where doctors have been targeted.
The thing is, in most of the other places
where we see it, the doctors are being targeted
by the state, not by random protesters.
So I'll give you some examples.
We know that early, very early in the Corona
virus outbreak in China, there were doctors
who were starting to see the spread of Corona
virus and they were talking about it.
And we have a number of reports that law enforcement
authorities showed up at the homes of some
of these Chinese doctors and said, you've
got to stop talking about this.
You can't keep talking about this spreading
virus, which at the time we knew very little
about and had hadn't really identified.
This was in late twenty nineteen.
So certainly we've seen antagonism of doctors
in China.
The difference is it's not coming from random
protesters.
It's not coming from media in the same way.
Maybe state media.
But we did see law enforcement antagonize
doctors in Russia.
We have a number of reports of doctors who
were working on Corona virus and speaking
about coronavirus who fell out of windows.
Now, I don't want to say more than what we
know.
It sounds weird to me.
It's like those stories of, hey, someone fell
on a knife 10 times.
OK.
Well, what do you mean they fell on a knife
10 times?
There are reports of multiple Russian doctors
that were making public statements about coronavirus
who fell out of windows and died.
I'm not going to say anymore because we don't
know anymore.
But my point is, I am not aware of the loud
public campaigns against doctors who know
about infectious disease in other countries.
But we do know, I guess we could call it hostility,
hostility towards the medical community from
some state governments.
And there's probably more examples that I
haven't mentioned.
But an important question and I mean, listen,
anti-vax exists in a lot of the world.
There isn't you know, when we started seeing
the measles outbreaks as a result of communities
that didn't want to vaccinate, it wasn't just
the United States.
We have a lot of them in the United States.
It wasn't just the United States.
When we look at protests to reopen.
It's not just the United States.
We saw them in isolated spots around the world,
but it's mostly in the United States that
we have this phenomenon.
And I don't know, you know, we can make a
lot of broad claims about what it says about
society or we have the most stupid people,
we have the most stagnant, but whatever.
We also have some of the smartest people and
a lot of them.
A lot of them.
But there is something cultural here where
these ideas get a life of their own.
Media will often give them oxygen.
And it's definitely very, very bad here.
No question about it.